[Musik]
das ist nicht das leben das ich die
versprochen ab ich habe hier ein leben
voller magie und wunder versprochen
die unsere beiden mädchen an ich habe
alles was ich möchte genau hier wenn ihr
euch etwas träumen könnte was wäre das
in vilbel gebrannt oder ein live lange
tacos
mädels ich glaube ich habe eine idee
ein ort an dem menschen dinge sehen
können die sie noch nie zuvor gesehen
haben dieses vorhaben ist ziemlich
bizarr die menschen sind von allem
fasziniert was ungewöhnlich und makaber
ist okay da ich vorstellen der berühmte
irischer reese ich bin können ihre
arbeit noch an ihrem akzent
die werden doch nur über uns lachen
wir lachen sowieso nie bei uns ist doch
besser geld dafür zu bekommen man ist es
jemals genug für dich
es geht nicht um mich
[Applaus]
ihr dürft nicht ob sie höher die
verstehen das nicht aber das werden sie
sie holen leute jeglicher art zu sich
auf die bühne und präsentieren sie als
gleich wird
es werden mit jedem tag nähert
demonstrant
wir riskieren alles was sie aufgebaut
hatten sie das hätte ich nicht schon
längst du brauchst nicht von der ganzen
welt geliebt zu werden nur von ein paar
wenigen guten match
hast du kein schamgefühl vater die welt
verändert sich an deiner welt möchte ich
nicht andere sie haben uns ins
rampenlicht gestellt sie haben uns eine
echte familie geschenkt das ist
es hat noch nie jemand was verändert
indem er so war wie alle anderen
politisch kommen
ab vierten januar 2018 nur im kino